regrettable to say that too little  progress has been made in the talks  between the institutions and Greece and  that no agreement as yet is in sight  there's not much time left to avoid the  worst in becoming days therefore  decisions have to be taken we are  waiting on the nose in situation that  aunt the institutions have put together  some very sensible proposals the efsf  has dispersed to Greece 131 billion euro  we therefore own about forty percent of  Greek public debt and we are the largest  creditor as you know there's the last  year as f tranche of 1.8 billion euro  available for Greece if the review is  concluded successfully